اينما تولي وجهك في رفح اقصى جنوب قطع غزه
فالصوره
متشابهه خيام ونازحون ودروب معاناه لا
تنتهي وزي ما انت شايف لا ملاق خشب ولا
ملاق ميه ولا ملاق حمام ولا ملاق على
ناصيه احد الشوارع وجدت ام فهمي وعائلتها
مكانا لخيمه لا تقي من برد الشتاء ولا من
قصف الاحتلال ع الشار وع الرصيف ور
صغار ومجاري ووحل وميه ووسخ يعني
عيشه بالواحد الحمير الله يعزك ما تقعدو ف
هالعيشه اللي احنا عايشين
فيها الخبز يا خالتي اما توفير القليل من
الاكل والشرب فهمه
قاسيه لا
كهرباء لا ماء لا غاز هذا السائد في
المشهد وعندما يتغير الوضع قليلا تصير
مقومات الحياه شحيحه للغايه ويضطر
النازحون للعوده الى الطرق البدائيه هنا
قاعدين بخبز بنلم كراتين عشان نخبز بنلم
الاكل عشان نشوف لقمه العيش صح ولا لا
ساعات بنلاقي وساعات بنلاقي زينا زي الناس
مش على قد انا بحكي زينا زي الناس والحمد
لله بنقول الحمد لله على السرا والضراء
كانت اقفاص الدواجن ملجا ام محمد بعد ان
ضاقت بها الارض هي وعدد من عائلات
النازحين شفت عينك احنا في مزرع الجاج
الميه بتنزل علينا من فوق هي على السطح و
وفيش معالم للحياه حتى فش عنا ميه فش عندي
اولاد عندهم ربع عندي انا اولادي ثلاثه
عندهم ربع للاسف لا قدره اوفر لاغطيه ولا
قدر فرهم والله العظيم ابني بنام على
البلاط وعلى قفص الدجاج ووضعنا سيء جدا
الاطفال هم الاكثر تضررا في الخيام او في
الاقفاص لاحقهم البرد والقصف وانتشرت
بينهم الامراض فاضت رفح بالنازحين اليها
مع تفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه في كل انحاء
قطاع غزه لكن ورغم كل هذه الظروف
الماساويه فهم يصرون على ان انهاء الحرب
والعوده الى منازلهم وان كانت مدمره هو
سبيل استمرارهم في الحياه على ارضهم وفي
ديارهم هشام زقوت الجزيره رفح
فلسطين